habe ich da bock
auf
nee
jetzt trotzdem
leider ja
agieren auf schule nein danke die
17-jährige doro lebt noch zu hause und
hat heimlich die schule geschmissen
ja das habe ich schon so ein standard
beginn von der hilfe der folge sie will
sich mit ihren kreativen ideen
selbstständig machen
sie sehen das bild jetzt das diesen
hilfen leuten dann auch nicht auffällt
herr in den ersten fünf sekunden hängt
direkt das bild menschsein war trotzdem
hoch selbst ihre ältere schwester und
engste vertraute tine weiß nicht es
hängt schon ihr können wir den leuten
ruhig an thomas edig mutter gabi 1900
längerem keinen draht mehr zu ihrer
jüngsten treffen
guck ich mir ein youtube video an oder
ist jetzt ein hörspiel streitereien
gehören zur tagesordnung
und was hier leider nicht zur
tagesordnung gehört ist ein
funktionierendes video das ist doch
richtig mütter mäßig näher wenn ich weiß
ich also wenn ihr geschwisterkinder habt
ihr kennt das bestimmt ihr habt
schreiben euren eltern oder nachrichten
eure eltern dann extra laut mit euren
geschwisterkindern mensch das geht echt
gar nicht klar was luca wieder gemacht
hat so dass jetzt auch höhere hallo ich
bin auch im raum niemand soll von dem
geheimnis der 17 jährigen erfahren von
dem geheimnis was hat sie denn kein
geheimnis dass schulden
du solltest vielleicht mal zu hilfe
das ist mir ja gerade gibt die post her
was hast du im rücken ich hab ich mich
warum hat sie eigentlich nie verstehen
sondern ihnen gürtel so
macht ja keinen sinn sind auch die
lieder in ihrem pony so haben und haben
die um den pulli die uhr um die ganze
zeit mit zu reden halt den mund zu
lassen ich lese in fresach mehrmals
schon hat die doro hier öffneten sie
sich ein bisschen aus wie laura müller
in junge ja oder auch nicht dass ihre
tochter du nicht im unterricht
erschienen ist schön wo und was hast du
zu sagen keiner braucht sowie kapiert
einfach nicht dass kein bock mehr auf
schule habe aber irgendwie haben auch
mal kurz auffällt die haben auch nicht
mehr ihren standard backsteine der grund
die sind jetzt so weit dass sie hier
dieses haus dann auch nehmen
es geht voran mit hilf mir
die trend geht nach oben geht es nicht
zu beginn der gefühlt jedes bild gehabt
jede machen karriere du sollst in die
schule sollst du hehre ziel ist es für
die dr dr
die doro hat ein kreatives ich
das geht nicht in der schule
das kann jede frau hoffmann da dem
sommer immer verstehen
doch das sind keine armbänder die vidal
gerade bei kik gekauft hat
das ist das kreative ich von doro ist
lästig schmuckdesignerin das ist kein
beruf und bistum des tiers kapern
anwendet
ich habe mich grad voll mit meinem
arschloch auf die ländergesetze
schmuckdesignerin ist kein beruf frau
beginnen berg
jeweils ich denn da
sehr wohl ist das beruf bis zum platz
der schwarze schafe in der familie das
allerletzte was die
denn jetzt
es hat mir so leute plötzlich
reingeschmissen werden von rtl den und
erzählt euch jetzt was sache ist jemand
in der familie als schwarzes schaf
behandelt hinterlässt das spuren
befragung und sagen das sind 70 prozent
aller familien ein bevorzugtes kind gibt
so wie lang musste ich für meinen
gameboy kämpfen
14 jahre und meine schwester war die
liebe kommt mit 11 oder weihnachtsbaum
ja da kann man auch mal den ganzen tisch
von rotz wenn es hier um die wahrheit
geht gleich die mutter ist aber auch
frech so klar die doro die schwänzt die
schule und so aber die mutter ist auch
nicht gut
wie kann das wagen frau beckmann hagen
einzig ihr nachname wagen beck magen
lernt zu lesen doro ist wütend und
enttäuscht über das unverständnis ihrer
mutter kurzerhand klaute die spardose
ihrer eltern dass sich war soll als
startkapital für ihre geschäftsidee dino
ich weiß nicht was wiederum machen soll
sie hat nur noch flausen im kopf
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht warum machen sie hat nur
noch von außen gekommen die dem er es
versteht sich von selbst dass entschluss
steht fest er sie zitieren traum durch
mit 20 euro wird das auf jeden fall was
du trägst die daumen durch die beide
darum die frau becker hoffen berg da die
sollte man ein bisschen halblang machen
oder ein viertel lang oder gar nicht
lang machen da es sind sogar 80 85 90
der 500 euro
schön habe blick doro und das warum
hängt das am fenster ich will das jetzt
auch nicht eine große glocke hängen
ich würde am liebsten nicht nur eine
kleine glocke am liebsten gar keine
glocke hängen aber
ich esse ja sowas schulabbrecher ich
mache meinen schmuck design dingen
schule und soll es ist also es für old
school
ich glaube wenn sich so eltern von
irgendwelchen zuschauern von euch ist
sich dieses video von mir angucke und
einfach ironie nicht verstehen
ich denke auch sofort er ist kein guter
einfluss für mein kind er solle das
hatte ja und genau deswegen solltet ihr
zur schule gehen tun dass zwei kleine
traum tape sich mit einem eigenen design
selbständig zu machen brauchen wir nicht
nur ten sie liehen warum so viel geld in
werbung und marketing investieren und
unternehmen
euro wenn du da bist helfer branche
komme ich wünsche dir viel glück für
kredite oder förderprogramme muss man
aber in der regel vorher einen
professionellen businessplan vorlegen
[Musik]
das kannst du doch ganz gut sagen was
man da vorlegen muss einen
professionellen businessplan
ich weiß ich also hier und da von allen
ich sage das ja wirklich in jeder
reaction von mir und ich weiß dass das
mega viele von euch aufregt aber keine
äußerung die stetige oder irgend lachen
oder so es beleidigend gemeint und noch
nie hat dass jemand auch so aufgefasst
um gottes willen ich glaube die meisten
kennen da meinen humor aber ich bin sein
so witzig ich finde hilf mir so witzig
das ist nichts was ich in meiner
freizeit angucken würde aber wenn ich
weiß so käme jetzt kaffee vor was zum
lachen dann schaue ich die hilfe folge
es ist das ist wirklich comedy pur
[Musik]
die meinung